متلازمه ثوم ماسك والمفاجات من مجال
الابتكارات اقتحمت السياسه بعصفه لم تهدا
منذ ان تسيد الملياردير المثير للجدل منصه
تويتر
على حريه التعبير التي بددها بقرار
التعليق حسابات صحفيين امريكيين وحتى غير
امريكيين ومستقلين وفي الاسماء تتخلص
المفاجاه دونيه الصلبه من سي ان ان راين
ماك من نيويورك
ماسك المعروف ابيها واهل جمهوريه
الانتخابات المصريه ابهرت ذلك انه
الانتقام وفي بعض القرارات ثائرا شخصيه
قبل ايام اوقف ماسك حسابا اتتبع طائرته
الخاصه من خلال تويتر الانتقادات واللي
ماسك اخذت من حنان جديد وتهديدات وصلت الى
احتمال فرض عق هات هذا موقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي فهل يتوقف ماسك غرد مجددا وبغموض
قريبا ايها الساده والسيدات رصاصه الرحمه
وعلى من سيطلقها ماسك
يفتحوا ماسك صندوق تويتر الاسود
وبذلك يثير عاصفه من
جهه والتجاهلات من جهه اخرى فما الذي
يريده ماسك من تسريدي ملفات تويتر مسلسل
وثائقه تويتر الداخليه طالت قضايا مختلفه
تظهر كيفيه التعامل التعامل المنصه في
الاداره السابقه معها ويبدو ان مصر جزء
جزء تلك القضيه ولا على القضيه التقرير
صحيفه نيويورك بوست عن نجل الرئيس
الامريكي
على قضيه الرقابه هنا قرر تويتر حضر القصه
على المنصه ومنع انتشارها نشر نشر القصه
وقتها
فزعمنا مع اقتراب موعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه فالتقرير تناول بيانات
من كمبيوتر فتحت الباب على ما قال انه قيل
انه استغلال لانه نفوذ السياسي يتوالت
حلقات التسريب
ظل او التقليد السري لوصول الاشخاص الى
محتوى معين لمستخدم الماء المسؤولون في
تويتر يسمونها فلتره الرؤيه فيما يراها
اخرون قمعا
كشفوا كشف المستور لم يقف عند هذا الحد
فالمنصه لديها قوائم سوداء سريه تظهر ايضا
تظهر ايضا ان الاداره السابقه لتويتر كانت
متحيزه لاطراف في مقيدت اخرى